yeah it's frustrating as well when you
know you want to resign you want to get
out there as quickly as possible but you
have to wait for your opponent to come
back to shake their hand yeah yeah oh
and look at that is that a smile of
resignation from jana pognaci yeah i
would just throw in a spike check yeah
he knows it it hasn't been his day
simply no that's the event commission
there are a couple of moves a couple of
movies you could play it's brutal to be
a sports uh person or a top athlete you
can have bad days
it's just so brutal when it happens in
the biggest moments in your career
like this a world championship match
oh
yeah yeah we saw jan exhale deeply
he knows it's over head in hands he's
about to resign i think yeah his
shoulders
all the pain oh well i can't help but
feel for you know
so much work so much effort he's put in
training in getting ready for this match
and he will be thinking about all those
previous decisions you know such bad
decisions that he took and that's
painful